Bebut oh god. Oh god. Oh good runs a crime. Oh
God why there's so many
Back to chicken
Show me guide me veteran of minecraft. Where are you? Oh
My god, I'm up above you I think Jack
Where are we or plane crash honey? We?
I don't even have a skin yet. Oh man upper ode. What is it called important? I won. Yeah, like default skin
T44 skins are the new meta. Okay, I'm gonna dunk on some babies in this game. Wait. Why? Why are we up here?
What are we doing? So I don't know what this is either but we're gonna play survival
But the world is amplified. So I think it's like crazy structures. It's time you see there's like an island in the sky over there
Yeah
more
Okay minecraft gods cuz I'm on ok
I'm sorry, am I able to jump off into that water tower?
Do you think I'll make it light died completely if I try that is tempting that that is some I enjoyed
How about you jump first? I'll give you a push
PewDiePie pushes jacksepticeye off the cliff. Oh
Did you really
He doesn't sound like you made it he can't even aim for this distance I eat like shaved at the edge
Who's so close you're gonna have a sprint bro, bro
Oh
Epic minecraft
Minecraft thanks. I didn't swore. I didn't swore. I didn't I tried to high-five. You didn't always say. Okay Jackson
It's gonna be nice. We have to prepare our boot our home together really living
We roommate we roommate we built crib also since this is start of new. Let's play I give you this here you go Oh,
magic flowers I eat no, I
I can't eat it
I'm going to die my belly red. Oh my gosh. Okay. Where are we going?
I don't actually have a plank where you need to find like a good good place right fine be as always
He just dig straight down and live in a hole but like an ostrich
Exactly hide your head in the sand. So I'm gonna go to the middle
Little sheep, three little sheep?
Nani oh my god. Do we kill take wool make bed
We give flour to sheepie in this you burn what is wrong with her faces. Ah, never mind there normal
There you go. I give a I give him flour to a chicken
Okay. He just run. This is the hardcore mode of playing mine crime be nice to ever
Whoa, whoa. Whoa. Whoa, this world is crazy Jack wait
What just melting the whole forest already? That's
That's life just don't go near the lava you will die. Okay, there's a forest fire as well
my god
Global warming even take over minecraft my god. This says so much about our planet. There's gotta be just a floating in the air
Yeah, it's so weird
What five out of eight robot? That's okay. Can't you minecraft to eat in real life?
There's a huge waterfall over here and well sight of the cliff is just water god damn place is weird. Yeah, it's cool
I'm glad this isn't my world. My world is peaceful as dogs in it you give on dogs already
Yeah, I would say spoil ease but episode already go up. How come whenever we record together. I just turn it to you
To do
This is it's not even my accident no, it's
It's just a weird voice. Do I plant tree help in vitam? Oh my god
We had give back with solve global warming look big happy dead. The fire will go away now
Don't kill Pig not killing a petting with flower. I'm petting to get meat
Good piggy, what'd you do to pig? I did nothing to pig. He just explode and give me his flesh sister
Where are we going? We need a plan. It's gonna be night time. We're gonna die immediately
Least you're eating while you're gaming. Alright how you know, I'm real gamer. At least we have waterfall to help climb. Oh,
Look at us already minecraft veterans, even though you've you've been playing it for a whole month at this point up I go
See you later mortal. I have reached the source. Okay. Alright. Okay. Good idea. Are you ready to take this seriously now, I'm ready
There's a waterfall next to lava for love of waterfall. We can make cobbles ideon. We can make a
cobblestone generator
Spawn wait, here's the ocean actually that might be good like we stay by the beach
Yeah, just like Brighton just like Brighton we're relieved. Oh, you think I can jump on cloud. It's catch
maybe you like
Okay chop wood, let's go three two one shop shop shop shop shop shop
Felix has played a lot of Minecraft now Jackson
He's starting he can teach him so much you shop wood shop shop shop shop shop shop little man. Oh wow
Okay, I dare you to hit I dare you to hit the pool down there
Yes, I
Take all your things they're mine now Jack
Jack yes. Are you gone forever? What are you?
I'm at the bottom of pool I survived. Oh my god how you jumped so well because I good I play minecraft
We haven't done anything, okay
Okay. Okay. I'm buddy. I might a double waterfall. So all my knee. There's creepers Oh Jack Oh God
Minecraft scary time now I hate this this game is legitimately sky, no
No told me like oh this stupid kids game. I'm
Creepy oh
I kill sheep. Now remember when it was my suggestion that we should play in hardcore mode
You're the first to die. Oh god. Can you come to the double llama?
I mean the why don't the double obviously with lava right now. It's really freaking fer me
Okay, I hit back. I'm at forest fire
Okay, I think I hear you. Ah, it's a creeper. Maybe we should show me your name all the time. You could always look up
Did he hear that explosion? No, then you know, it must be close
If you don't hear it, that's mean, you know, really that means you're deaf now from explosion
You cannot hear it?
Are you splashing in water? No?
I don't wanna go too far in case we end up going I one of us should really stay in one place
This is like getting lost at the store. Okay, mom. I'm sorry. I take serious. Haha. I will find you
Don't worry. I'm at a forest fire though. The trees are burning I get more wood. Okay, so I am at -
Thanks. I'm at - 169. Whoa, that is bad number is not a swore
You saw I have to punch you there. Let me fight. You didn't sward
Know it's fake. I'm at - - OH - now I'm we should be pretty close to each other then I'm minus 160
Okay, you went past me impossible
and then okay, what's your
Z then o
My Z is minus 354 - 220 Oh God, I have to go. Yeah. Yeah go down
I'm gonna die from falling out this. Alright. Yeah, I'm getting better. You're minus
200 230 40 okay. I see you Jackie. There you are -
Yeah, you look changed you look different that's not me if it's fake back
My god, it's a fake Jack. He swore, you know, we should have built the house by now
We should have like pickaxe we shouldn't start mining
We should have a diamond pickaxe by now
okay - 200-some be
zombies I run run run I
Hope my creepy doesn't get me. Okay, so - turn is 63 about two giant waterfall again
Tarantulas it creepy. Oh I'm starving so I can't run way scream
I hear you jack
Wow, alright, I got it I got it I kill myself to it and then will spawn sings black
Genius maybe we should back out and not do like such a crazy world because it's kind of what do you think?
Yeah, this is this is way too vertical
Dang it. Okay, so
Default and we call it
No, it doesn't count epic sward just because you're not in the server doesn't mean you can't swore no lets me
No one can join it's reset. Oh
It's fucking annoying type of voice to make entire - Scandinavians lost in Minecraft
Is this even Scandinavian? Yes, of course. This is how my parents speak when I board helmet Oh
swore
It is good. Oh good swore. Hey
high five
High five Sheep - the Sheep sheep - bye hi back. She white - father my unit I buy back huh? Oh
He's giving me flesh. He offer flesh does where sheep go now I can high-five with the Sheep high-five
Now you can high-five sheep with sheep Wow
Is this crazy?
minecraft
Thanks, not use it great. Whoa
Okay, so we should play maybe should we play seriously?
Okay, maybe like before the Sun goes then we want at least have a house right
Okay, I get would you get I get would you get wait, but what do I do? Maybe you get hurt maybe hurt
I make crafts Finch and we both can utilize but we have to share share care
sharing are
Caring good
God you I got can I have one would I make some plain? You know, I don't need it with
What?
Everyone needs a quid. Oh, it's special wood is special wood for special people. Okay. I need more anymore
I used up all wood to make stick for some reason I
Make stick for later. I'm still I'm not new but I'm still stupid
Make this crap again. Oh, I need a break for I'd see crap
Okay, I'll make wooden pickaxe that's good remember to replant tree to save environment
I'm all about minecraft baby. Okay, I think this is a physical blinks actually good look look fellow Scandinavian
There is a little feud here we can stay in flue-cured
Already lost you friend's
Name already disappear any lost boy
We walk around each other
Battle to death question mark why /n?
Okay, okay, maybe maybe just give little tap talk a little sister, okay, please hit once out of system. Okay now we safe
Maybe little stone here. Oh, this could be our little mind. Oh,
You and there's no maybe good timing. Oh, I'm more advanced than you. You small brain. I be polite
If you don't get there soon you're going to be smart, all right, I will get diamond before you
probably right, you know what to do a brain took me two took me two hours yesterday to get
Your small work and it stops you
I was watching some of your after I like played some of it myself yet
I went back and watched like your first episode your spawn was nuts
Was it really you got so many like good things you might like
people and you you went down you got diamonds really quickly because I'm trying because
I'm veteran Jack
No, cuz you sheet I know you should say I shake but your shake always do not cool
- fuck cool. I like that. Did you get any? Okay. Okay, we now we got to make a little smelting machine
You have cobblestone Oh
Copley I got here you take this. Are you ready for epic epic time?
Boom, what did smell te what did you do? Yeah, we need coal. Can I oh what you can't smell it - smell
Yeah, I did that in my episode. Everyone was like you did you did it wrong, but you still got the same answer
You know that cool wood also burn inside it now they yeah see I teach Sam
gamers teach each other even though I'm still using my hands -
Okay, you're quite hardware I get iron pickaxe stop advancing aaron ages before me
Yeah nose-mounted ma'am. Oh my god. Is he allergic to smoke?
Damn, honestly, we got sealed pretty fast. We should speedrun this beat dragon first episode
I don't even know what dragon is spoiling spoil East oily. So sorry about that, bro
I only got to nether realm and then got scared and came back
Yeah, first time they around was like no hey
III got my thing and then I got obsidian. I was like I probably shouldn't be
Okay, we need coal cuz I can't make torches
Okay, why don't we make this our mind then and we started mining down just like it because we both have Steel X
That's what I do. Look I do already Oh it'sit's not steel. It's iron. Okay, Edie, of course. Sorry, it's iron
Hey, come on
But we don't have torch I steered you got the man up
My cookies. No, you got the men I
Meet cooker. You got two men. I need I need sustenance to get low but where you get to meet
People like Jack and Felix should really play Minecraft together than his
Not like this
I
Can't see anything Jack. I don't understand why it dark
Okay, I kill sheep and then get won't Macbeth. Maybe ask sheep for a call Oh
Sheep. Whoa. I found the shaft right away, dude
Really?
How do you do that? I don't know
I'm gonna call you shaft from now
Call me chef Orion. What is the spooky sounds that keeps happening? I'm scared
I think it's when a monstrous pawns in a kid, but I'm not sure no, holy fully freak eats Mickey
All right. I see you see the cold. No, it's not. It's next to the llama
me scared of lavador
Hey careful, what are you don't be hero in Minecraft the rule. There's a chest here bread tonight
We eat gamer. Have you got pumpkin a melon seeds and a name tag?
Which means if we find a pet we can name it something
Also how that works. Yes. Oh my god have any song you're learning you're throwing crafts
You're improving its person. Honestly, we're pretty lucky from finding that so fast, I think maybe
epic gamer we play games
Jesus love almost kept me. Hey, hey, hey danger danger stranger danger. We don't have armor backup, Rebecca
Are you ready for epic? I put torch
Everybody do you have sword right? Yeah, maybe I'm in the wallet go back
Okay, I find I find they back my thoughts I can get well yes we grab them right did you want any steel
Yeah, you stole I made the stone
You swipe
Dog, give me give me all my things. Maybe we should cover up his lava. I feel like yeah, let's see
So what do you want hands put you one for me? I don't have
How can he slap how can you sled okay
So you had the iron pickaxe?
Yeah, there you go these sir and the me some more in that gray wool and the thing and the sword and the shovel
And the thing and I and I have second pickaxe
Should we explore this right away. I don't know. Uh
I don't know. How epic do you want to be? I don't want to blow people's minds, dude
This place is mess evasive. That is great
Great just great projecting
Jeepers Creepers
Oh, did he get the shiny? I got everything from check again? Oh
Oh, man. Okay. Do we need more call this co-sleeper down?
Need to smelt these multi. So a minecraft tip is to place torch on left side
so when you go back you look at other side and you're like
Oh this where I come from or just find diamond right away now
How is so so smart, I know you're thinking and how are you so at remind another hole it could do this mine is insane
There's a wiser. There's a sheep here. I mean for what are they called?
Chicken
What this freaking most common meat animal he can be friends we don't have okay wait, let's bury him here stay
Stay here. Suffocate. The little cheapy stay we come back very soon. Oh, there's lava lava down here. Lava and water
Maybe we shouldn't go down too far
Yeah, I'm scared. Mom. I don't have any what level are around 21 if we go down 10 more steps, we could find diamond
Right away, which would be kind of good mean
Okay, let's go together. Let's go down here. Okay
Watch out for creepers. I'm nervous
That's not the pro gamer tip that I learned Jack you press f3 and it says 11
This is the level. I already learned I get diamond to myself on level 12
Oh, you know how you know this?
I know how can you know this because because it took me 2 hours and I had to look up how
Okay, well I guess not there cuz I thought level people might get them 11 12
I thought that meant you go down 12 love
Oh, no trying to count from make the water level be like, okay
If I go down 1 2 3 4 why not work we probably should like get steel and sink get some armor
Before we go down here. Yeah do that. I have I
Have 12 so I could probably make a couple
of 6 iron ores now it is
Steel, well giant water pot lapras place
That's what I say that waterfall and thing down here. We should even look at first diamond blue. That's not time indeed
Laughs, it's blue what color?
Diamond time in this e3. I meant clear like your ocean high. So, thank you. You're sweet Scandinavian. I noticed my eyes. Thank you
It's the first thing I see when I wake up in the middle
nice look at
Well, this looks like a shrine room dude. What is this? You should build our base here. Yeah, that's awesome
This is like an evil lair. Yeah, I'm scared. Maybe we go back
I like that you put down torch, even though lava here brighten up everything
Be quiet, oh look we found obsidians that turtles spawn obsidians
Diamond. Okay. Well, I guess no lucky ducky
But we find what this rights don't actually do
You kids not like to trigger mechanism. You can make should we bring sheep to surface? No
okay, you can make like
wires and
electrical components and epicness
Contraptions contractions. Yes, like the ones your mother have. Hey, don't talk about good mama septic
I like oh wait, where's our way out?
Not there, I
Can talk normal now, it's been too long
I'm just talking monkey. Help me Jack help me, aren't you hungry? I have bread for you. Hi. I have meat bro
Maybe we should have built a little house here where we check
Where is our thing here, but we can make a new one. Maybe here. It's nice
But why would we put here and then not move Oh, what is that? What is big tall black figure over there?
Okay. Should we kill him? We now will probably die. It's too dangerous. I
Don't know if I just boy like suffer you don't know yet I just do that. Oh
Jesus okay. I found secret mining place from creeper creepers. Our friends just go over and give them a hug
Do not hurt you if you nice. That's the pro trip tip
trip
We are taking poacher. God know what I feel about having someone point out. How dumb I am all the time
Where are you? Are you by the thing? Yeah, I really feel like it should show our names a bit further than it is, right
What should we build next we should definitely make armor so just melt as much iron as possible
I would say I do I have beetroot seeds a pumpkin seeds. We can make a farm and make epicness
Do you have any coal could you put that in this one? It's in the furnace
What did you make a second one just so we can burn faster? Okay, and then I do this look Punk
Oh, we we put the Oh Jack. I put everything that I don't have surprise for you
Train go very fast. You have to be careful though speed these keys reduce the activation, okay
I I also have this look
Wait, how do I drop everything at once? Damn?
It was in chest, dude. All I can do is think about Minecraft lately. That's all you need
It's the best and now we played together whole new world, okay, go inside and I push you down. Okay, stay
It's like Disneyland for free happy you made a armor in your I make metal pants now metal pants
Like shiny metal. Look at my shiny metal ass, sorry
It was out, I'm sorry. Well metal pants almost look like apron you ready to cook little boy
Okay, I can't make anything else I'm melting more it's okay, it's okay, I'll make us helmets and then one was we're ready
We're gonna distraction. I can't wait to destruction. Oh, it's morning time. Look morning
Morning we should actually I know this sounds really pretentious, but we should actually place our house. So we see the sunset
Okay, I like that. That's not pretentious wait, which is better sunrise or sunset. They I think they go in bow
No, wait, we want sunset. Sorry. Yeah. Yeah sunset. Okay jack. Here you go. Now we both look very
big rained
a big helmet because big brain
Yes, big cube. Brain. Okay. Well now I think we should melt all of it. Let's see what's left. Three more. Maybe we make a
Ayran, sword. I want to shield. Oh Camry. Yeah, we should probably do a show. Yeah, we can make cousins are so annoying
I'll make you want
I
Have
Epic whoa wooden sword no. No. No, I got you
Okay, how much iron did you have? I grabbed as much as I could that was the point that was plantation
I'm sorry, I sighs. Oh
We have to name tags, let's listen we're doing good man the power of friendship when you work together
You mind together gamers help each other. We are too strong. There's no other video games in 2019
This is the only one that mattered. Can you believe minecraft invented video games?
Okay. Now the boys go down and we are not afraid boys mine
Boys mine, no girls allowed down here. We should explore the mineshaft by a chef mind. What is called Minecraft?
Should be gratis we can make epic rollercoaster sure. What's best item - Oh pickaxe to good pickaxe to strong
maybe we should close off like areas that we
Maybe judge Oh
Should make you up absolutely kill. Absolutely
Welcome to our town and now we with sweet land. Let's close this up so we know I
Usually cut down the pillars too because they make it really confusing
Do I need X it's preferable. I
Don't have then don't okay. Got it. Big break. Very very
Okay, I get all cold just so we have and I feel like I'm actually doing yeah, what are we searching for? Exactly? Um
There could be a spawner there could be
More chests I think is the main issue our main thing with the shadows
And just like exploring it see what's in this
You mean have a little fun time little fun time in little Minecraft's nothing nothing here. You didn't you did not okay
I closed off then close close and then
What about here Steve?
I'm stickin spider Oh monster acient
Judaism oh
Wow, oh oh Jack you fallin hurt. I fallen made poopoo. Help me Oh No Oh,
Oh
Scary skinny what take a teleporter behind you he shot me. I'm not today. Thank you Oh
Creeper ISM, whoa, we found a spotter. That's awesome. Holy Frick. I never found even in my own
Weight they're poisoned run Jack run
Minecraft is a scary game for not babies. I thought it was a regular spotter. Dang it. Well, he's scared now
Oh he running away. He backing up in the water
There's a creeper ism down there and I'm worried. Hey creeper. What's your name? Oh
man
How did you do that if you have the shield your protection wait, why is it bright here Oh,
Good question lava buh-buh-buh-buh-buh. What this what happened? Put this down here Oh,
Scary oh, whoa, it continues to shat. Oh
Good you are so good. I found gold it wait. What?
Wait, really. I found chicken place it all connects to chicken. Wait. What? Yeah, this is River before Oh,
More gold
It's iron pepper
Epic chest over here Oh guys don't know God Oh run. Yeah
Oh god why there's so many
To get back to chicken
The goal the hell is happening but the goal mommy should not have come in here without any food
Can you handle Oh God Oh God
Okay, I don't want to jump into your zone because I am afraid I'll end up hitting me oh god I'm gonna die
You have one heart, okay. Let me get them
Oh
the golden are
grabbity
Cold cold cold cold time epic cold time should we leave?
Maybe we should not be greedy. Maybe we should be strong strong like the Vikings of our forefathers forefathers were like hey
Let's not be pussies
Wait, sorry, where do we come from? This is epic way out
I do little hope to get out we should end do it making bed
Okay, but then we have to kill sheep. I kill sheep now. No, we don't
I'm not killing them. I'm putting them to sleep. Okay. I also coach sleep. Okay, and maybe I just killed it'll piggy
He smells so good he smell good I have to kill
I'm a vegetarianism real life but in Minecraft like everything is
Killable our home very pretty. Ok. Let's make bed. Ok. Yeah, I have I have
Three wool and ok, ok
Let's place down the bed. I don't think it's gonna be nighttime for a bit exam. The Sun is way high in this case thing
It's ok. I cook. Ok, let's get some food and we wait does the sleeping reset your health now? It just resets the day
I like how now I'm doing a survival. Let's play with you and I'm doing my own survival. Let's play the springtime
Well, I guess I'll I'll be do the same technically. Do you have more coat? Could you put it on the the other one?
No, it's all the coal ahead. Oh wait I have would freak
So that was like a
Villager that turned zombie before I don't know if you saw that guy who looked like weird. Oh they're corrupted
Yeah, I think it was I think that's quite rare
I don't know but I find bunches of them in my place room Oh Sun setting Sun setting time for bed
I'm just want to get to sleep the way you gotta place your own bed. I don't have a bed
Whoa, I gave you my wall to make your bed. Ah
You know what? This means we have to shoot
You to share bed with me nothing minecraft only real life okay, I sleep back now
My bed no wait
Why can't the nut make the bed a regular bed? Come on, we need to make bed. I'd I'd look for sheep
Oh so very darkness bear if target Oh get acquired. How does it work when you sleep in multiplayer? Actually, yeah
I don't know. I kill Pig because
Cows ease and creepies and she pees
Destroy the beat them all you have to kill the mannequin, but there's a scary scary man's killing me
Okay, I think I have it. I also kill sheep. Excellent retreat. I don't remember warehouse
Just keep running again
Follow the moon
And then bed. Okay. I got it. Okay. I need to put up like a barrier against
These you mean like building house
Yes, you make barrier. Very good
They stick out I'm not fast
Okay, take that, oh no another one
Man
Trying
Look you can jump on bed, you know this it's balanced fans
Wow, alright gamers
Hope you enjoy first episode smash. Like if you want more a million million double million likes and more episode and
Several beds for you. Good night gamers. Good night. Sleep tight top of night storm of the night
What you never played to simulator
You know, it's fun right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is available for free and that's a great price